i don't know like sometimes like
i hate comparing myself to other comics
or i'll see a comic selling more tickets
to me and i'll be like ah
wow but i i i've learned to like take a
step back
i don't for one i don't run to social
media if i have an issue with something
or i'm going through something
i go okay is it worth it to really post
this because
i've realized a lot of things are in
your own head well
i'll give you an example um when we were
shooting the first thing like a man
uh you know kev's he's the top dog
stand-ups right
so he invited he invited all the guys
out to come see him at the laugh factory
jerry romney ellie and terence
but i didn't get invited so we go to set
monday
and everybody's talking about last night
at the lab factory and i'm going
what and they all got pictures on like
twitter and stuff and i'm like
i did what and then somebody said gary
why didn't you go
i go i didn't know anything about it and
then
kev literally just goes you ever feel
like an
[__] sometimes
but i i think it was just i'm a comedian
and he just assumed i would know about
it or i just hang out at comedy clubs it
wasn't personal
but in the home and i found out i was
like dang
what's wrong with me you know what i
mean here i am a grown man
worried about what some other dude is
talking about and feeling left
out when i really shouldn't have it
really wasn't a big deal
it was just one of those things probably
out of sight out of mind ah
yeah i probably should invite you but
but it was a lot of it was in my brain
too
yeah that's i think that's good for
comics to hear though that even someone
at your level
even has to deal with all right stop
comparing myself to someone else
or like well this isn't some conspiracy
to hold me down this was just
circumstance like even someone at your
level
still has to remind themselves of those
realities
and i would tell comics too like don't
rush to social media if you feel like
you have
somebody's having an issue with you you
have an issue with them
i know because i've said it numerous
times in the past
you don't know what's going on behind
closed doors with these studios and
networks and your name
can be getting tossed around and then
you say something about somebody
attached to that film and all of a
sudden
you're not in the running anymore it's
like man
i've seen it happen a few times i'm not
gonna say names but i've seen people
like we were about to hire this person
and we're like don't wanna deal with
that dang
high breath
you